[Music]
[Applause]
we're lucky to have Jerry West the Hall
of Famer and uh Clippers consultant won
an NBA championship in 1972 certainly uh
cross paths with Bill Russell quite a
bit and uh Jerry kind enough to join us
on the program Jerry let's start with
Bill the player if people didn't see
Bill Russell the player how would you
describe him
well I think uh Dan
um obviously
he was the most unique player I think
that came into the league at that point
in time
uh he was uh kind of a forerunner of
what we see today these active big guys
who can move out in the court he can
play he could play out in the court but
his activity level was probably what
made him stand out more than anything
particularly on the defensive end and I
think that that was the Advent of people
starting to understand the importance of
the defensive play in this league and
what particularly what one man could do
to disrupt other teams
it allowed you to do so many things to
hide weak defensive players players that
sometimes people will take advantage of
and they were smart enough to use him
the right way he they would funnel guys
to him but uh to the driving to the
basket he would alter shots and or block
shots that seemingly took away two
points and also
ignited what they like to do best is
went up and down the court
but more than that um
uh he's a man who probably changed the
way the sport is looked at today
everyone looking for a big gifted guy
and over the years as we've seen the
changes in the game uh particularly
because of the three-point line I think
his unique style of play will
be what someone is looking for now more
than ever in the sense that hopefully
there will be a better offensive player
than he was but uh remarkable player but
more importantly a remarkable man
how where were you of Bill when you went
to the hoop
well early in my career uh Dan because
you know I'd never seen a player like
this I was probably an athlete before my
time could go in there and jump over
most people you had to really be careful
with him and early in my career he
really bothered me a lot because I had
the ability to get by people and uh with
him back there he had to learn how to
either
make a pass and which would help players
if they were gifted enough to do it and
then more importantly how to look for
him before he got there that was most
important thing you almost had to
identify him and I was able to do that
later in my career and had much more
success playing against him because of
uh because of being and wherever he was
all the time
also he's one of the first and you would
know better it felt like he blocked
shots and kept shots in play whereas
Wilt might have blocked them out of
bounds it felt like Bill Russell blocked
him to then start a fast break
well there's no question and today he
watched players uh you know block shots
and everyone gets really excited about
them blocking the shots into the stands
and everything it would be nice if they
could just tip the ball to their own
people and uh my goodness when you're in
driving situation Dan it's the ideal
time to run out on teams uh because
teams are anticipating maybe an
offensive rebound they'll be leaning
toward the offensive end if they're
offensive players and the defensive
players if a ball is is tapped or
deflected off the board or someone
that's when when today's players really
take advantage of open courts because
they're so good in the open courts today
did you ever talk about you guys meeting
in the finals did you ever get a chance
to talk to bill later in your careers
about playing for championships Dan he
and I are probably a lot closer than
anyone would ever thought
um I'm happy to say that I was a friend
of his I knew a lot about him personally
uh we shared a lot of thoughts
um some of the things that uh he he's
said about me will live forever and I
have something in my bathroom that I've
had up there vividly displayed in my
bathroom for years and it was the night
that they had had a night for me here in
Los Angeles and he had said something
about me that has resonated with me for
years and he he talked about the respect
of of players in the league that they
had for me the respect they had for me
and he also said in there maybe more
than any man I've ever known but the
last his last thought was he said I just
wanted you to be happy
and uh over the years uh you know he was
great friends with uh uh Jim Brown they
lived together uh talking about how they
could help make a difference in minority
communities be uh be people who helped
keep in sight what their focus was uh
one of the things they used to do and uh
both Bill and Jim I talked about with
Jim too they used to drive across the
country together every summer
and I and he would bill would laugh
about it in the sense that he said can
you imagine
two giant black guys drive driving out
across the country in some little small
town and they pull up and hear the here
are these two legendary sports figures
but more importantly
um just how committed they were to help
making a difference in the minority
communities and the awareness they
brought to the athletes in the league
even at that point in time when was not
invoked in at all
he wanted you to be happy
what did he mean by that
um
well Dennis you know it's pretty well uh
known that uh you know I've had some
awful dark days in my life and even
still today and uh coming from him I
thank the uh the pain that me and other
players that play for the Lakers that
point in time to get beat by them I
think eight times in the finals uh was
really very traumatic and uh at the
height of my career when
you know I could I didn't take a back
seat from anyone at those days and uh it
had come up short all the time and
particularly to the Celtics it was uh
hurtful it was uh even to this day I
think about it um
think about how people might view you as
a as a champion and even though we won
once and I played on a lot of great
teams a lot of success afterwards it was
not the same as uh the team that you
really wanted to be were the Celtics and
because they had such great Excellence
uh what he won 11 championships as a
player coach uh it's pretty remarkable
that I don't think we'll ever see a
winner like that in any sport again
because I'm not sure it's it's the
leagues are established that way today
players traded free agency changed the
destiny of a lot of teams and also when
you lose a player of his caliber if you
can imagine if he would have been a free
agent what might have happened then it
would change the Dynamics of a lot of
teams we look at Michael Jordan as the
greatest of all time but Russell's the
greatest winner
um why don't we recognize if winning is
the ultimate why isn't Bill considered
the goat well today we honor individual
achievements you know I watched today in
sports and and here in Los Angeles uh
and uh in Orange County we have two
incredible baseball players
uh on the Angels teams that uh you know
everyone doesn't understand why they
can't win obviously they're not good
enough to win Mike Trout and uh
Otani and I look at those players now
Marvel what they're able to do and be
the most valuable player on a team that
wasn't a great team at all last year and
Otani and I I say to myself uh you would
think that those Awards would be given
to teams on winning team but they're not
they're recognized as uh for individual
achievement but again as I say today the
sports have changed completely uh you
know it's about it's about
self-promotion it's about uh also a lot
of about social media and there's so
many kids today who are really into that
and I think probably one of the things
that's most shocking to me is when go to
kids go to college today and they're on
their own these social media Pages they
have thousands of followers in in places
that you you never heard of basically I
mean instead of the big cities where you
expect most of publicity to come from so
there's a different approach I think to
sports today than maybe we've ever had
before and uh Bill's Excellence not only
as a player but a human being will far
outlive some of these others in my mind
I believe
how is red Arbok
during a game to you you ever say
anything to you
no I didn't talk to anyone Dan I really
didn't uh you know everyone used to get
when he would like it light his victory
cigars I heard a lot of things sitting
in our locker room with particularly at
one of our late coaches about what he'd
like to do with that cigar and
and obviously he never had a chance to
do that because we were never able to
beat them I had great admiration for
them but there were two years that uh
and I'll say it to the day I die
um
that we should have won we had the best
team and we did not win and that's
what's even more galling when those
things happen but uh you know you have
to I think you learn from lose uh losing
uh you have to learn to lose with class
but it still doesn't take the hurt away
if you care more than the average person
and I always felt I did care more
if you could replay one game in your
career
oh my goodness
oh boy I think maybe the first time we'd
ever uh played in the uh NBA finals and
and we get beat in a seventh game in
Boston Garden in overtime
there was game was tied and and Frank
Selby who was playing for us at that
time he and I are in a backcourt he made
a shot to put us in overtime and he
missed one that would that would have uh
that would have wanted for us and I
always
used to love him almost like that and
they had double team uh me and Elgin
Baylor we were playing together lady I
was in Baylor who also was an incredible
friend of bills
um and we were not able to get the ball
and uh you know people will talk about
Frank uh for missing that shot I will
never talk about him because he made the
one that really mattered and he was a
very good shooter he missed a shot that
I'm sure a lot of us would like to have
but that's Sports uh that game I just a
lot of nights even today I go to bed and
I said oh my gosh I wish I could have
had that for the last shot and again I
don't know if I've made it would have
made it or not but it's something that
um that I wish I'd had an opportunity to
do
the winds don't stay as long as the
losses do right
no absolutely not not with me uh you
know
um
I have very high standards Dan in terms
of what I felt as an athlete uh you know
I felt that if you could play you played
uh we played into a you know a lot a lot
of different times a lot of different
eras when when the league was just
changing frankly bill and I think Elgin
Baylor and myself we bought a different
perspective from an athletic standpoint
that's a league it didn't have then
there were a lot less great athletes
like today's game we've seen enormous
athletes today and you just see them
getting better and better and all all at
all time and particularly with a lot of
the things that we see players do today
but you know it was a very prideful time
for anyone who really cared and those
times were the most meaningful times of
my life because winning meant everything
to me and even today it still means
probably more than uh more than most
people would ever imagine
in that series You Average 31.
Elgin averaged 40.
that window like he's the first true
athletic superstar in the NBA and I only
saw him at the very end when he had his
knee injury but just knowing what he did
how he did it at that time it felt like
elgin's maybe the Forgotten superstar in
NBA history well I've said that a lot uh
Dan I think he was so quiet
and he just let he just played the way
he played and to watch him some nights
how you say oh my God uh you know where
did this guy learn how to particularly
shoot the ball off the board and he had
amazing instincts to rebound the ball
and particularly on the offensive end uh
he was uh and even a better teammate but
he has been forgotten there's no
question about it and I think uh he
averaged 38 and 18 one year Jerry well
you should know this 38 points 18
rebounds oh my gosh yes I mean he again
he just he was an athlete before his
time and his just do has never been
there for him and I think of the problem
that happened he got hurt a couple of
times later in his career which which
really were at a time of his career when
he was just still a great great player
and at that point in time obviously the
doctor in medical care was not like it
is today and it did Rob him and for me
uh to watch someone who I loved to watch
play when I was playing with him some of
the things he would do and people I
think people say well how do you even
concentrate on that well for me it was
easy uh just the ease that he would do
it and and instincts or something that
you wish all people had uh and
particularly great instincts which he
had but he was a remarkable player
himself and as I mentioned when we used
to go to Boston uh I would if Bill would
have invited media house and I really
didn't even know him because I was so
quiet
um he and Elgin used to have dinner
together Will Chamber and he used to
have dinner together and he used to act
like that these guys hated each other
and it was just completely opposite and
I think it was about respect about
respecting uh a black athlete
relatability not only to be players but
be treated at human beings and that's
exactly what he was about about a player
and also his activism was incredible and
I applaud him for that but we lost a
giant of a man not only in person but in
stature of what he accomplished in this
league and be outside of the league
that laugh there's no other laugh like
his
yes you're right absolutely he was just
a wonderful man and uh I will miss my
times just every time we saw each other
we always ended up together some way
somehow and our talks never varied they
were always the same in his famous uh I
don't call it laugh I call her cackle
yeah that will resonate in my mind
forever
always great to talk to you Jerry thank
you again we appreciate it well thank
you so much Dan that's uh Jerry West a
Hall of Famer Clippers consultant he won
the title in 1972
NBA Finals MVP in 1969 when they lost I
think what 14 years 14 times an All-Star
for Jerry West